In order to reach this top level, to
be successful in Formula 1, not just to
drive, that's what I realized at some point
that
I don't have that and then my
manager at the time told me that you
can become a professional driver, you have
money  earn but my advice is
you are much better at entrepreneurship
and as a manager. I
ran a racing school for
him at the time, I dealt with the customers and I
had to raise sponsorship because that was
because I had no money and he
said you are coming here  Back in the day
and do Formula 1 or
company okay so
welcome to the OMR podcast for a long time
on my bucket list finally a guest
I don't think I have to say that much
toto Wolf hello toto hi hi so
people know you where
you arrived today so to speak  you are one of the
faces of Formula 1 but what
I think very few people really know is that
you have taken your first steps,
among other things, in
digital business, yes absolutely
after racing where I tried to
make a career, that
is  Due to a lack of resources
I was basically a child of the
early internet boom in the
late 90s and as an investor I was
not with money but rather with equity
for
consulting
You bought the one Austrian
messenger service that existed back then,
we're talking now in 1998, and
you bought it from a young developer and
impressed him by the fact that you
drove up there in a sports car, but
it wasn't a Mercedes, it wasn't a Mercedes,
no, the story is one
a little different, I was in America
and came back to Europe
and of course
I noticed the beginning of netzcape and
Yahoo
EOL in the USA and I thought to myself, what is there something
similar in Europe
and of course there I was, I'm
Austrian  So of course it was
obvious that I started in Austria
and discovered that
the largest website in Austria, sms.at,
was a messenger service and it
belonged to a young man from Graz,
I think he was 17 years old at the time
and I went to him  There was
no company at all, let's say, it had
everything from the children's room
and Austria was so
huge but the Austrian
telecom providers kept
trying to talk him out of it and
I said how do you do that? He did
I said yes, I just hack into the SMSC
into the server and if I don't
go through Austria then I go
through Sweden or Nigeria and
we did that together in a company
and then raced capital and
it was then
at some point  bought out and
then it became a relatively large company,
albeit with other partners, but it
was your first
big economic success, so to speak. Then
no, there was one success before
and that was a company. I don't know
if that still exists today, a game
software  A company called Jowood
that grew up in
German-speaking countries with
a game that was called Industriegiant
and I found it in Steimmark, I
went there and said I think I
can tell you what he said we'll
do  little turnover for an IPO and
I said well that's possible in
Germany at the moment companies are
IPOing that don't have any turnover at all
and the deal was if I succeed in that
then I'll get 10% in the company and
that's what we've done.
We have one  did a capitalization round
and then listed the company
on the Vienna Stock Exchange
iPot can clearly remember it was
unbelievable because it happened so quickly and
that came before the messenger service and
SMS then became something much bigger,
a company that was called UCP
recently  I met Ferd Porsche, I
think you know him
too and he told me that when I
talk to you I should definitely
talk about an even earlier business idea, namely that you once
sold candles and that
Ferd Porsche was in your head  a
young generation, a cool
personality, um
and it's good to see that such young
descendants who also have something in their heads
and and character yes the
candle story is a different one, um and
in the year I think 1990 there was
quite a political shift to the
right in Austria  JK Heider and
then there was a
demonstration called lichtermer
against this
shift to the right and this demonstration was a
peaceful demonstration was for was
announced for the entire city center of Vienna
and lights more inevitably means
light in the evening and and in the time before
iPhones the only option was that
to do with torches and then I had
the idea that I would buy all the torches that were
available in Vienna and the surrounding area. I don't know
how much they were, but there were over
100,000 and then I got them. Of
course, they hardly cost anything,
just a few groschen
and the piece and that was just
complicated to get all these torches into an
apartment in the city,
I don't know how many trips
were necessary with the Golf that
I had at the time, then we
set up this camp there and all sorts of
school friends
activated and these to sell these torches at various
critical points in the city
and
nothing worked so it was announced for the evening and
we started there in the
early afternoon and it didn't work at all,
we didn't sell anything and then
suddenly it's in  Momentum gained
and the demand was so great in the
90 minutes before the lights
that the three of us just walked
around and tried to
free the sellers, let's say, from their cash
because they were afraid and
and and I told the story  Then
I went to our strongest saleswoman,
a school friend of mine,
and the demand was so strong that she
just said that the candle
costs 20 shillings, so 1 €o today and
then asked the customer how much does
the drip box cost  and then
said another five shillings you ca
n't sell the drip carton extra
and she said oh the
people pay for that they really want that
so the first lesson
m of let's say supply and
demand if the if the demand
is there if you that  If you get the timing right,
if it turns out to be a desirable item,
then you sell it and
if it doesn't work, you can't sell it at all. It was
a really good first lesson and we
also donated a large part of it,
of course, but that was a promise
before your digital age, you were there
really still a teenager or something like that, it sounded like
you were 18 yes 18 and then you did
n't start your whole self-employment, so to speak,
straight away, but you were also
employed for a while in the steelworks I read or the steel factory as a sales person  er or as an
assistant to the sales manager and
then you saw how he simply
put together prices and then
slapped fairy tales on it, okay, I can do that
too, now I'm self-employed. Yes,
I really learned a lot. I have to say I had a good
boss, a sales manager
took me to task on the first day and said now you're going to make
me a budget for next year, the
word budget, for me that was just a
term from the news budgetdeizit
deficit or a budget for one for
the Austrian Republic but there's something there
Budget for a company means
I didn't
know at all at the time I was a 22-
year-old college dropout
racing driver and I said okay, how do
I do that and then said look, you take the
previous year's profit and
loss statement, look at which customers
we have  Look at the countries and how
much we have earned and then try
to explain to me what we can earn in the
different countries next year,
look at the history of
these companies with us and give
me a first look at it. I think
that was the
umbrella area  for everyone like we'll
do next year and then he
sent me away then after a
few hours I came back with my first
draft budget and he then made a mess of it
and said that's wrong
and that's wrong and that's wrong
and  That's how you do it now and then
I spent the next few days really
learning how to budget and those were
very important lessons for me and then
the
owner was the sales manager and
then he was fired and the
owner W wanted to appoint someone new
and
the entire staff who
worked there really
stood behind me and said
that of course for a company
that was quite large at the time,
making a 23-year-old sales manager after a year was
perhaps one  big step,
but I did that for a few months
and then got to the point
that I realized I
just don't want to be an employee and
look after someone else, I want to
do it for myself
and
then I have this product and all sorts of
by-products  I was taken over by a
representative in Poland, I opened an agency
with two Polish partners,
my mother is Polish and I speak the
language and it was clear to me that instead of
calculating margins as I was told, I have
a corridor depending on the size of the
customer depending on the market  At
some point I started to calculate what
he actually earns from the orders
that I process and that
came together because of my travels and I
thought I would do it myself and
then I took this product and a
few others from other companies and
then I got this first one  The company was
set up and how I ended up in the m&
sector was also a coincidence
because one of our largest customers
went bankrupt and we had
outstanding debts with us and
that would have meant a big problem for us
if we didn't say so
recuperation again and then
the idea came up let's
buy the company and then for
the first time I came across words
like due
diligence, what is the M and really
learning on the job, that is, your
whole early phase, so to speak, you were
already there  Was it
already entrepreneurial, so that you then
financed your own racing career, which was taking place at the same time, or was it
somehow time-related, so that was, so
to speak, you were still a
driver at the time, or that's how I
perceived it, I once read a sentence that told
me that  somehow
applies to me once man of a single
task
when I'm a little behind behind something there's
nothing at all left and right then I give it my all until I do
n't enjoy it anymore and that's why
racing didn't take place at all
I don't think I have a single
race  Seen
in the years, let's say in
the in the next six or 7 years
everything was about the company
then the deck area was added and it wasn't until the
end of the 90s that
a friend called me and
said come on, let's get in  Let's do
a long-distance race, he
was also a former racing driver, he
said, really, I have
n't done that in years, no, we can do that, we
can ride a bike, you can do it once, you can do it always, and
so I slipped back into this, let's say,
track  that I
went in parallel to my job,
like other people went to play tennis or
golf, and
your companies that you took over,
how big were they at the time, so they were
tiny at the time, so probably by
today's standards 10 million euros in sales,
so very small companies  but
it didn't matter a big company or
a small company you buy very
similar parallels but I mean you
somehow, so to speak, at some point after you
managed to get a hold of Formula 1,
you also bought into the
Renault team or something like that  It then
slowly starts no no kudos to the Williams team
William Sorry yes
yes William team yes but that has a
long history the Williams team
came much later I have the I
then set up
a junior junior program with Mercedes-Benz
and we have young ones
Racing drivers were developed and sponsored and
50% of the budget came from Mercedes and
50% from
me and with a business model
behind it that if the drivers
earn money one day that you
can earn it back like a venture capital investment and that
went over  It was good for many years and it was fun
and one day
I can remember clearly we were sitting in the old möwenpig
Hotel at Stuttgart
Airport and
the decision was made: should we take driver A
or driver B and then we
decided on one and in  After
this conversation
that evening, one of the managers
said why don't you buy
into HWA and
I said HWA yes HWA stands for
Hans Werner, the founder of
AMG
and then I said yes but that
The AMG and
Mercedes have been sold, no, not the motorsport division,
the motorsport division has been
separated out, spun off into its own
company, which now belongs to the owner
and that will be fine, you are
such an investor, I said
okay, then I'll talk to you
upright and  Then we came to a deal.
I bought 5 49% of the company
and I had a lot of fun
being involved with management. The
main activity at the time was the DTM and
that was huge in Germany,
so maybe it doesn't exist in that form
anymore, but  That was the counterplay to the
Formula 1 in Germany factory motorsport
Audi BMW and Mercedes and one
day there was a call from Mr. Mateschitz's office asking
whether Mr. Mateschitz
could come over because he wanted to
sell the small team to Tor Rosso and he
thought and he thought  that we
would fit in. At first I thought it was a joke
because Red Bull was already a
real player back then, but
the helicopter landed on the meadow
opposite, and the kid came
in and said you wanted
Alpha, which is now Alpha, and wanted to
buy the team  and I then
set my office in motion, which was still making capital, and
said let's check the case and we
then came to the conclusion that it
wasn't interesting because at the
time the big OEMs in Formula 1
were
Honda  Toyota
BMW Ferrari Mercedes with a
mclaran and there was
basically fire,
so no limit on spending and that
's why we said we wouldn't do that
and many years or a few years
later that must have been in
2009. Then I
met Frank Williams and sat
then in the office and said I have
heard you are an investor HWA is
a great company I respect
Hans Werner so much I heard
you can help me
repay my loan for my house then I'm sitting there in front of Sir
Frank Williams an icon  Formula 1
and said yes, let's
find a deal here and so it happened
that I bought 10% and then I
got almost 20
and then Williams was a partner, so
it was, um, exciting times
That means, so to speak, back then you were
already so economically powerful
that you could afford something like that because
I mean that means but
you then got the first money in the
gaming messenger service through these early transactions, so to speak, then the the
company where
you, so to speak, first hired yourself
That's what you worked out through
various dealings and
reselling, so to speak.
The HWA was also a really
important milestone for me, not only to
understand the business better
but also the sale of the shares um
and to W that sold um we  We
first sold it on the stock exchange, we
had a tremendous amount of demand when we went
public and then we sold it
to
a Qatari investment
family company of the Altani family that
did this business and so
we were I was basically
out again  the company and so the
resources came together so that I
could afford it. I never
took out a euro of credit
or refinanced myself with borrowed capital from the banks
because that was too much of a
risk for me, also because of the
past in my family where things
went wrong  is and so I was the
co-owner of Williams but
the Williams investment I
tried to pursue that didn't
go well for you or that
went okay because I
invested in Williams and we also gave
the company to the
uh in  This small segment of the
frankb of the stock market I can't
remember what it was called
brought um and then I got
out of there and sold my shares
again after a few years and
m that was basically the
idea that means
you really have, so to speak  then
sold at that level, so to speak,
in the sense of an IPO after a holding period,
then you don't do that
with ir pa €100,000 were
relatively large sums then yes, those were
large sums, so I think I
doubled or tripled the investment
but we already have the
company was valued at 40 or
50 million how I
got in okay so I
saw a bit of the stock market price
I didn't know exactly when are you
in when are you out okay but what
stuck with me from that time  The
research shows that you
had a driver at the time whose
name was Pastor Maldonado and who
surprisingly
won a Formula 1 race for everyone and
I think that was ultimately
a much greater success for you
than the economic one  Because that was
your ticket
to talk to Mercedes again, of
course, I always had a connection
to Mercedes, but the
sporting success was important and
we were underfinanced as a team with
the pastor as a driver who
wasn't Michael Schummacher  you can
say but a really nice guy, we
needed the sponsorship that he
brought with him, that was substantial and
I was initially a
non-executive director in the company from
2009 and then gradually
slipped more and more into active management and
at the beginning of 2012  the CEO
threw out and then
Frank Williams asked me where do you want to
do this together with me and then
I got myself a shirt with the
Williams logo and then
my name was on the other side and then we have
this we have this  We managed the team together
and put a lot of
energy into the company and
it became clear to me
how well a team
can work if there is a lot of
optimism and a positive mindset and
then, unbelievably, we
won with the pastor in Barcelona
and that was basically it  because
Mercedes asked me why
Williams won a race with de facto
few resources and how only
one and then you
gave a presentation to the Mercedes
board and explained to them you had to
invest more and how to do it that way
and then they said okay,
why not directly with you, it was the same way,
so they got me Wolfgang Bernh,
one of the board members, I
knew him through triangles, he then came to me and
said we can, so he
asked me if we could have breakfast
in  Vienna and that's what we did and
then I was invited then
nothing happened for a few months and then
I was invited to Stuttgart to
meet Wolfgang and Dieter zsche,
um let's say with the question
why don't we win we have a
Bought a team that became world champions in 2009
and we've only been
fourth or fifth since then and I said I'm
welcome to take a look at it but I'm
at Williams and I'm one of the partners and I don't
want to badmouth anyone and no
look at it then I looked at it and I
'm  came to the conclusion that their
expectations were simply wrong
given the budget
and that was no one's fault because the
team was bought by a relatively
large company with a relatively large amount of cash in the
company and the assumption was that we do
n't need any subsidies and that
we will do the same  to be able to
break even to some extent and still be
competitive and I
said what is what what are your
expectations and then there was the idea of
becoming world champion because that's why
we bought a world champion team
and my my feedback was then
one of us is wrong
I want, I have the same budget, my plan
is top five and you want to become world champion
and
m. We then
discussed it quite directly and robustly, the management also around
Wolfgang and them, no [ __ ] so
straight away and then the offer came
I went back then I was
brought back to Stuttgart and
the offer came. We would like you to
become team principal and
head of motorsport at
Mercedes and of course that is like an accolade for me as
a racing racer, it doesn't get any bigger than that
My predecessor was Norbert
Haug, who
shaped Mercedes Motorsport for several decades
and the team principal was out of brown,
so it couldn't be better. But
then I declined because I said I was a
shareholder in Williams and I would give
all my strength to this team
to bring back to the old glory and
as much as I feel honored, I have to
be an entrepreneur and then
Z and Wolfgang Bernard looked at each other
and said, we
thought that they would say that, that's
why we have the option of 40% here
buy to become our partner,
um we have just bought back the 40% from our
Abu Dhabi shareholder
and we would like to give you this opportunity
and then it was
n't a problem for you to raise the money,
so you had to finance it
or were you able to  you get in directly with cash,
no, so that was
a problem because we were talking
again in a completely different league
and I then said
I would like to do that, but to
be completely honest, if I do
that now if I do everything  If I put in what
I have then the risk would
be too great for me and then what kind of
purchase price are we talking about in the
order of magnitude, we were already talking about
100 million or something like that or what kind of
sums was the purchase price in the mid-digit,
how do you say in the middle of the two also in the
double-digit range  40 to 60 million something like that
in the range and
that was of course I didn't want to
and couldn't m I've
always followed the mentality of only
taking calculable risks, which
means I can live with the worst case scenario
and that would be it
not change my existence and that would have
meant that it would have changed my life a lot
if I
had lost this investment and in this respect
the board was very good, I have
such a large part of skin in the game,
they called it that, they actually
contributed
capital and  Then, together with Mercedes
over a few years, we found a model
where, depending on the sporting success
within the budget, there
was a success component that allowed me to
pay it back
Victory
or every victory was worth a million for me,
no,
it was completely wrong, it was more about
the final result in the drivers or
world championship and what that
would mean for the company value, so the
way it was calculated is that we
had entry-level rating and  Depending on the
success, I had a
put option to sell the shares in Mercedes
back at a certain
value because the way we got involved, like me,
I said what should I do with 40%,
it's a minority share in
a team, you'll never buy it again
and then they said okay, depending on
success, we would buy it again. They
gave me a put option with
an downside and a downside and
we were so successful from 2014 onwards
that this put option
developed very advantageously in my opinion,
becoming world champions for 7 years in a row
It was quite okay,
but it wasn't foreseeable. How much
in a world championship like this is in the
end, driver, how much is in the engine, how much
is in the end, so to speak, team boss, it
all has to come together,
of course the team boss and the driver are at the
front but on  In the end
we represent many 1000 people who work for these
two cars, who
contribute the engines, who design and develop the chassis,
the support from the
board who really let us do it
with a long leash
to represent this incredible brand in the
world and that has everything
contributed to the fact that we
are then successful - a good only a good
driver with a bad car the
engine will not win and in the same way
a good car with a good
engine and the bad driver will not
win so you have to cover all these
pillars, so to speak  In order to
be successful, it is still the case that
Formula 1 itself
has taken a different development in
recent years, I mean in the
initial phase we have just discussed,
other
investors Bernie Eckelone also played a
big role  and then I think there was
a crucial point in some way that
Liberty Media, the American company,
came in and changed the whole
platform again, or
at least from the outside it would have been,
but that was a long-term
process, i.e. that of my
early days  Bernie eckelestone
still ran the company even though C
wiec was the largest shareholder
but the fact that he made it big despite
his let's say despotic nature
pulled all the strings and at some
point C wiec decided
to sell the company to Liberty
and from then on  A new era has
begun, American management is
very
pragmatic, not emotionally driven,
that,
let's say, high and fire and
makiavelistic actions then stopped
and then everyone was on the same page
and then of course this
big competition between Ferrari Red
Bull and Mercedes came into being  In the
years that followed, Stuben and Hamilton
delivered a scary show and
of course drive to survive, without a doubt
in the covid years when people sat at home,
this show came along and simply
put personalities there and not
so much the sport  in the foreground um and
as far as I know we were one of the
very few sports that
raced because we did it behind
closed doors. I think
we did all the
Z 250 covid covid tests this year to
get this paddock in and that
was natural  a very
positive coincidence despite the very bad
environment, I mean in the end the
Liberty people
did everything that B didn't want to do,
so to speak, documentation social media,
so to speak, broadcast radio messages all at once on
Instagram or on tiktok
and that's how you were there  I was convinced right from the start
that you had to do it that way,
or you did, it was clear to yourself, okay,
now that's how you have to deal with the
Formula 1 platform. No, that wasn't
immediately right because
some unconventional ideas came up and Bernie
always said that was a mistake
Restaurant the Formula
1 and not a burger joint and as we then
social media as we said we have to do the
driving social media
he said the people who
look at social media are not the
customers of Formula 1 they don't buy
Rolex um and also  no Mercedes or
Ferrari and that's why I'm not interested in, let's
say, this target group
and then came Liberty,
the topic of social media was suddenly
opened up to young drivers who
were really, let's say, funny little personalities plus Lewis
Hamilton of course has one
opened up a completely new target group and the topic of
drive to survive was something that I and
Ferrari or we Mercedes and Ferrari did
n't like at all because they
hardly paid anything for the rights, they were
very intrusive, they walked around everywhere with their
cameras and that's why
we decided  don't take part in it
and my Ferrari opposite
said we are here to
win a world championship and not to do
Z,
um and so a year went into it which
was a great opportunity for Netflix um
out of a let's say um bad
situation because  Suddenly
they had to document people who
were otherwise never on the radar because
they didn't have Fettel, Hamilton,
or Rusberg, but then came Ocon
and Ricado, who didn't play a big role in sport
at the time,
and then a year later it
basically became that  The premiere was
this series was launched and I was
on my flight to Australia for the
first race and I thought
I'd watch it now and it was really
cringe worcy it was terrible so the
first episode was the King of Spain Alonso
against  science as if it was about a
world championship and de facto
it was in the midfield game for
12th place then the next one came then I
watched the next episode because
I wanted to give it another chance
after 45 minutes and that did
n't work at all, it was embarrassing  Besides, seeing all these
idiots, all of which I
have all year anyway, wasn't for me and
I came back and
forgot about it and said we were
n't going to take part in it anymore and then a friend called me,
an acquaintance from Vienna and
says she would like to see if it would be possible
to have tickets for the Austrian Grand Prix
said for whom yes for my two
sons who were 18 or 19 years old
pretty cool boys I thought they
were interested in the topic of Formula 1 yes we
love drive to survive that  the best
show and that's why we want
to watch it live and so I
thought maybe my
assessment was wrong and we then
it was clearly wrong
and we then agreed with Netflix
okay we'll give them a
race that they can report on
and we give you full access and
that's how it was and now
it's obviously huge, you've
become a completely different personality yourself, so um from
a let's say normal sports manager
now to a world star in your own right, that's
how you perceive it, I mean  I was
surprised, you still don't play social media,
at least not yourself,
that's a very strange
development for me because this, let's
say, this
recognition value to the outside world only
happened when I was well into my
40s, which means to
some extent  more mature in order
to counter this with a certain amount of skepticism
because when you grow up as a young athlete
or a singer or an actor,
it's completely normal
to deal with this kind of publicity, but for
me it came late
and never played such a big role
It was more like the
idea that it actually doesn't help much other than
getting a better table in the restaurant, but you could do more with it,
so if you
were to market your account now, if you
were to start one and then have
millions of followers
You would probably have that right away, um, so you
can
develop your own voice. Lots of CEOs in
the world would be jealous of the reach
you would have, but you don't feel like it,
no, I don't feel like it and it
was also the case that I have it for myself
I have a customer theory and customers are
the people who can make the life of my
family and myself better
and everything I have to do externally
is basically aimed at this target group.
My customer number one is
my wife and my family
are customer number 2  My employees in the
company and customer number 3 are
my colleagues on the Mercedes
board or our sponsors and
partners who help us achieve sporting
success and everything I do in
communication is
geared towards this and none of these three
customer groups would be interested in a
social media profile  from me on Instagram
and that's why I don't do it, we
try to keep our private lives
out of the media
um and it's also very strange to me,
I have to say
that managers, sports managers
or even entrepreneurs
run Instagram profiles where they
then look
into the camera like models  Well, laughing, that
's really incomprehensible to me and there
are a few candidates in
Formula 1. I think it's so
narcissistic and next to that when you
pose with your sunglasses
and look cool into the camera, like that,
I think now  I'm thinking about something
very important at the moment and that's
me and my drivers. I'm getting it
all together,
I know and you have to have your ego under control
and if you're not, you'll start
making mistakes, okay, but let's just say this whole
development has made Derag one for you too
I mean, this team had an incredible increase in value if they were to be listed on the
stock exchange, what would it be
worth? The Mercedes team, so I would have
said probably already worth
billions
or yes, we are now not
a trophy investment like it used to be
that someone  Wanted to have a share in the Formula 1
team because you liked the sport
but we are, let's
say, key figures that
result in certain maltipels and in America
this change took place 15 years ago or so ST
when the salary cap
was introduced and  suddenly to
avoid these different
billionaire owners constantly
outdoing each other with player salaries, so we're
now talking about NBA or so NFL NBA and
NFL so there's a salary cap and
you only have so and so much
to pay your 60 man squad and  then
you can decide how to
pay a quarterback 20 million and
then simply have less for the rest
and then
these companies started
to make big profits through
sponsors and in our case the
environment changed with that  the salary
with the
costc that we were suddenly not
allowed to spend more than 135 million dollars
as it started with the exception of driving
as the largest blog and marketing and and
that then turned our result se plus
and se plus is good we are
now talking about 100 million  The result is that it
really is a large
company with over 1,000 employees
now, no, so we have 1,300
employees on the chassis side
and then on the, let's say,
engine side, for which I
am responsible as head of motorsport,
but 100% Mercedes belongs to another
1,500  So the total is a big one, there
are two big
organizations and today we make
these profits are very cash fow
positive and this results in
multiples which are of course
only on paper because none of us
three shareholders we hold all of them
want to sell shares at the moment
Timing and that's why you can
do a nice calculation at the end of the day. At the end of the day, the
only thing that counts is the cash flow, what you
can take out of the company
or reinvest in profits, i.e. free cash
flow and not some
paper valuation but, so to speak,
applying your old playbook again and
something like that  to bring the stock market one
day that might already be
possible yes, although in 2020 the
covid has put a lot of strain on me personally
for two reasons
uh my contract has expired and
uh I'm I'm really good when I'm
running in the hamster wheel and when it's
is stressful and when the pressure is there so
there is no risk of burnout for me there
is no risk of a bout for me
and suddenly I was left to my
own devices to do something with myself
and then things did
n't go well for me mentally  for a
long time and then
of course I had doubts about whether I
wanted to continue, am I a one-
trick pony and do team manager and
team owner, or am I going back
to the field of venture capital and
private equity, which I have enjoyed for many
years?  I've been doing it for 20 years and
then I thought about it for a long time
and then came to the decision:
I want to do it, it's
my niche between investment and
sport racing is my passion, I know my stuff, I
believe in live sports
content, the resilience to covid
was natural  also something that
helped to solidify my opinion
and then I decided together with
Mac Cenius that
let's
continue this together in the long term and that's what
we did and this
decision to now be an owner
with Mercedes is something I think about
every day  tweak has to um
and
that's not an issue for the stock market and it's
not an issue to sell rather than pass on first
no I don't believe in legacy either the
children should do what they
want and if that means
being involved with their sports team then
you can do that  but the two
parents have no interest
or no great interest in motorsports,
my son is studying international
business and my daughter is studying
journalism, both on the
west coast in the United
States and that's
why that's Susi and my
career trajectory and we want to
do it as long as we want  We have a lot of fun with it
and not just
sell it to someone or something and if
we no longer exist at some point
then the children should do
what they want with it, that is to say a little
bit like
Nicki Lauder used to be  and bernieckelestone
so as an old person still somehow
as an old gentleman as a married couple
then maybe somehow still
watch Formula 1 then at 70 80
you're still doing it but
maybe in a different function
so today I can definitely
imagine that  Nicki was non-executive
chairman of the supervisory board and I'm
now
fully on the playing field, let's say,
as team principal and CEO and
maybe in a few years it will
be the case that I no longer want to do all 24 races -
I've been there for over 500 hours
Airplane a year um and I think
it was 200 hotel nights but a
little less and hopefully
build someone who can follow me who
can take on certain agendas
maybe not everything, of course I want to
have a certain credibility as a co-owner but I
enjoy Kia counting and racing but who knows  Maybe not in 10, 15 or 20
years and then
I will have a less active role in the
company. I wanted to address another topic,
namely you just
mentioned your daughter. There are also
various controversies surrounding Formula 1,
one of which, of course, is
the sustainability issue these days  and there
you were now on a podcast together, she
interviewed you and it was
exactly about these topics. You will
certainly be addressed more often. You are probably thinking about it,
how do you see it
or can you simply not answer the question?
hear more no very important question because
it's not just my daughter and
my son who are challenging me, they
are both 19 and 22
m, but that's also
a big topic for me,
I see it every day like what we're doing
of pollution
and I would
like to contribute to ensuring that our children
or our children's children can live in a world
where the issue of climate and
emissions is simply controlled as well as possible
and Formula 1 as
the first thought is totally
counter-intuitive
To associate sustainability but what because you
could say we fly pointlessly
around the world with cargo and people and
then drive pointlessly in circles, as
Nicki Lauder once put it, just to
provide bread and circuses and
it would be better that way  We don't do any of that and
everyone stays at home and nobody watches
TV on the weekend
to watch Formula 1, but it's just that
we said we are a
car manufacturer, it's the
fastest laboratory in the world, we can
develop technologies there on a prototype basis  which will then be found again in
the series
and we have been driving for
some time with the hybrid engine,
which has the greatest efficiency of all
engines, so we call it thermal efficiency
with more than 50%
and are now going into regulations
in 2026 where we will have 50  % drive electrically and
50% conventional combustion engines but
with a 100% sustainable fuel um um
and and thus actively participate in the
energy transition there
will be
one and a half billion cars in the world in 203
that run on combustion and if
we can prove that we  If we can use
sustainable fuel
not only efficiently but also in terms of
performance
and this can be
found again in the gas station network,
then we can take part in this
energy transition
or contribute to it,
of course, which the counter-argument would
mean let's not
drive cars anymore and not with them either
Airplanes fly
and let's say we
grow our tomatoes in our garden
but that's not the reality. We
like to buy things from China and
they are transported by ship
and then we actually really
like Amazon and we want the
children's toys tomorrow  The
best thing is that it flies
around with air freight
or is transported with trucks.
People will
always travel for business purposes. We want to
visit our friends and families. We
want to go on vacation and we
drive from A to B
with our automobile because  maybe
the bike is too far for the bike and that
's the reality and my case is that
if we can operate sustainably and
demonstrate that we fly around the
world, that we
send trucks through Europe and we can do that
with sustainable technologies
then it can  everyone and one example was
a presentation at a
sponsor where I said we fly
with sustainable fuel, i.e. sustainable
aviation fuel, which costs significantly more
than normal, but we invested
three and a half million euros in
sustainable aviation fuel last year and
at the same time we experimented
with sustainable fuel  Filling fuel for our
European
trucks into our trucks and
shooting me dead now is the number,
but 85% emissions reductions have been achieved,
which means we can show here as RLE
mododel in a real world how
it can be done better and what
we're trying to do  you still have
a lot of investments, I mean if you
think about it now you can read 100 million result
now in the past
year then 30% will flow to you after
taxes and everything but still that's
a lot of money and on top of that
you'll also invest other income
Do you still do venture PE on the side
or do you say no all focus somehow
like I just said
somehow one one so you just
coined the saying somehow so
a task only also or or yes are
you looking to the right and thing
I'm very lucky that I have one  I have
a friend and business partner who
covers this side and basically
runs our family office, manages our investments
from capital to investments in
various private equity or venture
capital funds to, say,
conventional investments in equities and
dead and that is our core business
and he manages it  I'm
also the one who has my back when it comes to, let's
say, shareholder
negotiations with Mercedes and Co. He's
the one who does everything, he's back
of house and I'm front of house and
these synergies between us
work well  Your question
yes, we make investments, we make
investments in all sorts of assets and
sometimes it goes well and sometimes
not so well depending on the market, but of course we try to beat the
benchmarks on the public
markets. You've
recently been with me in the business world  I
particularly noticed that you had the
honor of doing your own case study at Harvard
Business School,
but
it wasn't so much about hard
business but more about the
appropriate mindset, the psychology
behind it, so to speak.
Yes, I'm planning on it  A few years
ago I decided that I actually
enjoyed passing on my experiences, good and bad, to younger people and that started
with an engagement at the Oxford
Business School where I
am still an associate fellow to this day, which is
equivalent to, let's say, a visiting professor
comes and I try to do that as well as
possible, I enjoy it and
then
Harvard came with a
cheese study that Anita is the professor,
so let's say she's known for always
covering sports and media idiosyncrasies,
including Ferguson from Manchester United
before that and so came  with the request whether
she could do that through me and the team
and I found that
somehow honorable and we
supported her and gave her access
then we presented this kstudy
and then I sat there in front of
the postgraduate stents  at
Harvard and I had a lot of fun with that
and then the idea was
also this this this this this
guest so professor is a step too far
but basically gest lecturer
guest professor there
to take this position and this and then to help design
a course there again and again throughout the year
and  Now I'm running my own
course with Anita in January, which
runs over four days, about
these different topics and
leadership management under pressure and
so on, and also passing this academic
part on to the
young people. It
also gives me a lot during the days
Harvard catapults me out of my
environment, i.e. my
professional environment, it's
inspiring to talk to the people there
these four days I feel like
a student because of course it also
flows in the other direction from the information flea, not just from
me to the students  in the
other direction and that's something
I don't want to miss, um and and it
contributes more to me
performing better in my core business than it
spoiling me or what the number one
learning is now in a very short time if
I mean that's just a
little bit  unfair because the course
is much longer but if you now say
irwi management under pressure what is
so that if you now had a sentence
or your management sumary
for what do you do at best under
pressure to stand by your value
umm umm integrity honest modest
and if  If you combine these values
with competence
and interest in
people then something good can come from it
and I
am very interested in
getting to know people and working with them.
I can't develop an aerodynamic surface
but I know a lot about
my nerodynamics boss  The
time that is the C is the
couch sessions with me where I throw over every
schedule that my
assistants set up because I
just have a really authentic interest
in people and when we
talk about teams and and companies
what is that, that's kind of how it is
Such a figure but at the end of the day
these are people who are on a
common journey to
achieve their goals, their objectives and
if we manage to put the energy of all
these people behind this behind a
common goal then you have it
a huge amount of power to
achieve what you wouldn't even suspect
when you hear you say that you
allow yourself to be extremely coached,
so somehow I read about over
500 hours of therapy that you've already
had, I mean, um
Of course, um, it's a situation that
I've had to struggle with all my life,
the topic of mental health is something
that affected me a lot, especially
because of the difficult circumstances in
my younger years - my father
suffered from a brain tumor for 10 years and
then I was 15  died,
um, without any financial
background, so it was actually
that my parents tried to
keep me in the French school, which was private, but
of course that wasn't possible financially and
at some point they fished my
sister, who was 10, and me, 12, out of the
class  in the afternoon that
was quite unpleasant to tell us
we have to pack our things
and go home and then
of course I had
to explain to my young sister why that was and
um and that happened to me again and again
for many years
plunged me into major crises, um, which
I was somehow able to manage myself with luck at the beginning,
but at some
point it became so overwhelming
that I, um, and after I
tried everything from, let's say,
meditation, um, to
all kinds of literature, um, to
a happy life, um, then  Of course
I also sought help, I
achieved everything and at some point I
ended up with a psychiatrist and
told my life story in my late 20s and
he looks at me and says you should
become Chancellor or
Federal President, but I do
n't understand why you say, um
Suffering from depression and it was clear to me that he
didn't understand anything because
all the money and all the success,
um, just doesn't save you, let's call it that
I have always sought help from
competent doctors and coaches
and and it is still the case today that I
have difficult days, the big
crises that have lasted for many months,
which have not happened for a long time,
but I am never
immune to them mentally  Health is an illness
like any other for me it is I
call it
brain
diabetes brain diabetes with a broken hand
you go to the doctor or to the hospital
with a depression or anxiety disorder
it is still a stigma and
I am trying to break this stigma
um  I'm anything but
weak or anything but
fearful, but it can also
affect people like me and that's why
I have to pass it on. It's not a
shame, on the contrary, it's a
great power. We are sensitive so
we can sense things that others do
don't feel it but that
of course allows us to ramp up successfully and
understand people but on the other
hand of course we also perceive negative
vibrations very strongly much stronger
than other people but it has the
current sporting situation is
not optimal for you now so it could
be  It's better, but it does
n't have any interaction, so
to speak, one Z Sport has the other zag
general condition. I
've been feeling
very
good for many years and 2020 was more like the last time, let's say
where that
was difficult but as I
said before my comfort zone is
pressure is pressure and to pull
the Karen out of, let's say, out of
the dirt, to help
shape an organization and 2020 is
just like we won six or seven
titles in a row
It then became too easy and
then covid comes along and suddenly
you're sitting there dry,
nothing happens, the stress doesn't exist and that
was difficult for me times times like
this when it's about fighting
to develop a company iter visions
have the hunger to
be successful again that's like I said that's
the area where I
feel most comfortable is lewiis Hamilton the
best Formula 1 driver of all time from
your point of view lewiis Hamilton is
definitely the very best Formula 1 driver
because he has the most  Records are the same
as Michael Schumacher in
world championship titles, he has won more races
than anyone else, more pole
positions than anyone else, more
podium finishes than anyone else
and simply these numbers speak
for him as the best racing specialist, but
records are about to be broken
and  Maybe in a few
years in 10 or 15 years there will be
someone else who will be even better,
but now he is the best
racing driver of all time, what did
Lis Hamilton have, such a super driver, I
mean what you didn't have, you were
also short at the beginning  the Formula 1 you
were close to driving yourself
what where is the difference is it then
something mental or physical so
I wasn't close to the Formula 1 you
have to say I did all
sorts of junior formulas and m
and  was reasonably good there and
then also good in the sports cars or in
prototypes but it was me I was
relatively early on I always
knew what my strengths and weaknesses
were and was also brutally honest with myself
and there were moments where I saw
I was missing gokot driving, the
training in gokot and
maybe the, let's say,
to reach this top level, to
be successful in Formula 1, not
just to drive, that was
at some point I realized again
that that that I wasn't
My manager at the time
told me that you can become a professional racing driver and
you will earn money with it,
but my advice is that you are much better at
entrepreneurship and as a manager I
ran a racing school
for him
and dealt with customers  I had to
raise sponsorship because
I didn't have any money and he
said you would come back one day
and do Formula 1 but as an entrepreneur it was
unbelievable yes unbelievable and I
had that then
Senner and Ratzenberger both had accidents in 1994 in
May  Karl mänlinger died in
Monaco then seriously injured in a coma and
then my sponsor my main sponsor
said to I just don't want to
watch it anymore I don't want to visit you in the
hospital I'll stop at the end of the
season and that was at the end of mid 94
so I was
22 and then I said you know what,
I've already made this decision anyway,
let's stop now
and I was very far ahead in
a championship in a young
formula championship at the time and I said that
was it cut and I immediately started
working to simply get earlier  to be ahead
of everyone else in order not to get
trained earlier and to
understand earlier um and to be successful so
now the circle closes so to speak
because that's where we started
then your
entrepreneurial life, so to speak, began with the
different stages and the investments
and um yes  I'm very grateful to you that
you gave us the time
to tell it like that, tell me the
whole dead wolf story, I'm
excited to see what's to come, there would be even
more topics, I would still like to know
what you think about Las Vegas and all those
things  Maybe one day there will be a
great, unique thing that
they have implemented there, but you know
we can talk about it again in
the future. People always say how
successful and how efficient
and at the end of the day it's just my
own expectations, I'm not trying
anything  to do something for third parties um to
prove um that there is financial
or sporting success but it
's about where is what are my
expectations and
of course they change but that's what it's all about for me and I
would like to turn around when I'm 80
and say that  My active time was now
my professional time and then to
make a summary for myself
I fulfilled my own expectations
it was good enough and successful for me
but not at 50 I think
it is much too early there are many
careers that then go uphill  from
or steep hill and that's
why there's no judgment for me yet as to
whether it was all good or
not. What's more important to you is
the sporting success or with
such expectations
or in the end also the economic
side of the whole thing
There's this in both directions
but I'm primarily
racing oriented,
the stopwatch just appealed to me because it
's so honest
and that's why sporting success is
more important to me than economic success
but of course economic success
comes from after sporting success
That's somehow closely
related, thank you very much, I know you
have follow-up appointments, thank you very much for
letting me do it and I have a
nice offseason, what do you do off
season last thing what what what do you do
when you're flying around for a while, you're at
Lake Constance and and enjoy it  View
or is of course so that we that
I don't have a real offseason because
when I'm not at
the races then I'm in the office we
have our base in Oxford I have a
lot of fun
being there with the people and
My weeks before Christmas are like this
: I'm usually at home on Monday
and then on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday
or maybe Friday I'm at the
company in oxf and then back
home again. So I'll
basically have a conventional office for the next two and a half weeks
Job and
that's also important, is it actually true
that you show your employees pictures
of the same people, i.e. of the
people who do the same job at Red
Bull, for example, and say, look, this is
your opponent at Red Bull, that you
use motivational tricks like that, so to speak
I've been doing it for 10 years,
that's anemy building works well
that you that you whatever role you
have whatever job you have and
be a little engineer or a
houseusekeeper there's a opposite and
this person does a job and
if you're in  You can
do a better job in your area that you have influence on
if it motivates you if it if
you are tired then the sum of
these achievements will also result in success
and I said take a look at the
link
spend the time to look up who
does this job and
and people have these windows
open on their laptops, I have that
too, I always look when I use the
laptop hoffah in two faces are not
Formula 1 faces,
some have the photos printed out and
carry them around in notebooks, others
have them  it's pinned on your
desk
and for many that works but of
course there's also the other theory
that you want to create for yourself
and m and then you don't need that
but I think that this sum of all let's
say my sets worked for me
and a  A good example is
Lis works like this if you look at
the last dance with Michael Jordan it
was exactly the same, you had to
choose an opponent that you
wanted to prove it even if it
was some random guy and grandstand that's how
we work that's how we work many many
thanks for  the insights I think a lot of people
are up for the next case study
or your course or something similar, thank you for
doing it, thank you, it was fun,
all right, ciao ciao good, ciao take care